we'll start off today
with a status report on those ballots
that i've been talking about every day
that are still outstanding
23 000 have been counted
and we've got 39 000 of those 63 that
we've been talking about back and forth
ready to be sent to counting board and
finish off our count
we still expect that at some point
tomorrow
we should be complete with the mail
ballots that we've been discussing for
the past several days
the id deadline was yesterday
so work is continuing today to prep
ballots for counting on those
and just as a brief description on
exactly what that's all about there were
certain voters whether it be for
provisional ballots
or for mail ballots who were required to
provide an id
and they did not so they had until five
o'clock tomorrow
yesterday excuse me to bring in that id
so we have all of those
in-house and staff is beginning to run
through those
so those ballots will be pulled and
they'll be put put into count
for those that provided their id the
open and outstanding cures
on all of the mail ballots that have
been received is available on our
website and it currently numbers two
thousand
three hundred and thirty three those
voters have until november twelfth
which is next thursday to cure those
ballots
and they can dial 702-455-6552
to get assistance in curing those
ballots
we will continue to run two reports
daily so as i mentioned yesterday before
four o'clock we had released a second
report
today we will do the same thing i will
be releasing a second report and
if there's information to report
tomorrow sunday
we will also release a second report
sometime before 4 pm
a provisional update and i understand
that you've all been provided the
handout that we prepared
so i'd like quickly to go over those
so what i provided you is there anybody
who didn't get the handout who needs the
handout
okay good so what i have here on this
sheet is a breakdown
of the types of provisional ballots that
my staff is currently working on
to reconcile and determine which should
be count and which are ineligible to be
counted
first is the haver provisional and i
think dan also gave you some information
from our website describing exactly what
i have a provisional is but basically
it's
someone who reported that they were
registered to vote however they were not
in the voter registration system when
they came in to vote
so they voted a provisional ballot and
we have to do research to see if there's
something that we've done
that didn't get correctly done and they
should be registered but if they're not
registered then the votes won't be
eligible to be counted
we also have the same day registration
and the acronyms are i
o and u the difference between those is
that
the same day registration in person is
somebody who showed up at an early
voting or election day
site provided the nevada id that's
required by state law
and they were registered to vote on the
spot and given a ballot to vote
the same day registration 0 represents
the online
registration and voters were eligible to
do that until
october 29th the thursday before
election day
to register online which also requires
uh nevada id in order to go on and vote
the sdru is the simplest of all of them
it's an update
so as a result of changes in state law
voters can come in and on the spot
during early voting or election day
change their address
change their democratic party and
different items
so those are the three different types
in addition to the hava and my staff is
currently working
there's a fairly large group working on
verifying going through those because
the next step
and i have communicated with the
secretary of state's office
and they have confirmed that they're
going to be asking us for our first
report
on all voters who voted in clark county
individually
whether it be early voting election day
or through the mail
to them on monday and what the secretary
of state needs to do with that
is compare it with the other 16 counties
in the state of nevada
to make sure that we don't have any
duplicates in those that we voted
provisionally or that anybody has done
anything illegal
by voting in two different counties once
they run that review
they'll send that information back to us
on anybody who
ballot shouldn't be counted and will
begin to
in an automated fashion begin to roll in
those provisional votes which probably
won't be
any earlier than wednesday of next week
so keep in mind despite the mail ballot
ballots that we're putting through in
reading
we won't even have the capability to
enter these sixty thousand
which not all of those will count
however process any of those until any
earlier than wednesday of this week
so the grand total on the breakdown for
those provisional ballots is there's
twenty one thousand four hundred and
ninety democrats nineteen thousand
ten nonpartisan ballots and
nineteen thousand nine hundred seven
republican provisional ballots
okay in the report on u.s mail for this
morning we received
25 that's two five
uh ballots through the mail this morning
and then the process of being
reviewed and sent to count if
they are eligible and i've already
mentioned but just to close out
the cure process for any voter in clark
county
the deadline is this thursday the 12th
of november
and again the hotline number for
assistance on that is 702-455-6552
and with that i'll open it up for any
questions
thank you good morning um two for you on
the um the id deadline was yesterday
you said you're working on pulling those
do you have a number there were 44 000 i
believe outstanding that had an id issue
do you know how many were cleared
unfortunately i don't know exactly how
many of those records i can tell you
that we have a large group of staff
that's going through those to identify
them and start pulling the ballots
okay those voters can be counted i
possibly might have one
update for that for tomorrow but no
later than monday okay and just to
clarify the numbers that you gave us off
the top
um you said a total of 23 000 have been
counted
yes but that's 23 000 since when since
we've been talking about this universal
ballots and that 63 63.00063
23 000. it's 234.89
got it and then 39 000 left that is
correct perfect pretty closely adds up
to 63. and then just confirming one last
thing on these um
on the sdrs so you'll send that first
report
monday that's where we've been
instructed and then when you get that
then back on wednesday
the number whatever the secretary of
state tells you are eligible
how long do you think it will take you
to process those it is an automated
process
but it depends on what time in the day
we get them on wednesday
but we should be able to roll them into
the system if we receive it in the
morning
otherwise it would be on thursday which
is our last day statutorily
to get all the ballots in
good morning mr gloria i have a couple
of questions one morning
one on uh will you be open saturday and
sunday for curing
for people who yes sir the the hotline
is open the the
number that i advertise 702-455-6552
i want to ask about security there was
another protest last night
and others are planned we understand
have you heard or experienced any
credible threats
to your facilities or the count process
and that's a security issue and it's
more a question for law enforcement to
respond to
not that i know of can i ask how you
feel
fantastic would that be a
feeling of relief i don't think it's a
feeling a relief we're continuing to
roll through we're very proud of the
work that we've done and the dedication
from staff
we feel good because we're continuing to
report the work has not stopped
despite everything that's going on
around us so we've got a brave set of
workers who've been coming to work
despite what's going on around us but
that is because law enforcement and our
county management has done an
excellent job of putting the protection
in place for all of us to feel safe
coming to work and doing what we need to
do
over here
morning mr gloria you're experienced
professional could you
explain to us why almost 100 of the late
ballots
across the battleground states went for
joe biden
have you ever seen a situation like this
during the prior elections
thank you so much i'm not really
qualified to answer that you need to
talk to some journalists from cbs
and cnn and all that kind of thing i i
don't get into the details
of why valid shift or why count shift we
count ballots as they come in so we
don't analyze why it would ship one way
or the other
hi joe good morning can you break down
the timeline of when those
mail-in ballots that were walked up and
dropped off in person
actually first started being counted the
election day ones
so the election day drop-offs your
question is just to make sure that i
understand it
when did we start putting them through
the process correct
i believe those started going in through
the agilis machine sometime on thursday
afternoon but no later than friday
morning
what was the delay there because we
needed to get the computers that were
used on election day
the update that you had described on
wednesday started
that was certainly important i think
i've mentioned in my previous conference
that it's really important that we get
the database
updated with those laptops that were in
the system
so that we can have the computer do the
important work of kicking those ballots
out
for anybody who voted in person they
shouldn't have sent that ballot in but
we have to make sure that we don't get
those ballots in the system to be
counted so
yes that would have been one reason but
we were still able to read them in
and those ballots were um posted
and in queue until we got all the data
in over here
hi joe thanks for taking all of our
questions i'm gonna move away from the
speaker i just have two quick questions
for you first
in this sort of second half of the count
going towards
november 12th november 16th oh i'm sorry
i was just wondering you know how does
it feel in terms of how it's going now
versus earlier in this week what have
you guys
learned in this process
well in terms of how it feels i think
consistently through we've been doing
everything we can to keep the process
going
i can't nail anything down that
specifically slowed us down
i think it's very important that
everybody understands
mail for the entire voting group here
we became a mail ballot county in march
of this year
and so there's a lot of expectation from
people around the country and also from
the media
that we be as good at processing male
ballots as colorado oregon or washington
who have been doing it for 12 or 13
years
we simply don't have the equipment the
facilities
the staff that have been trained in that
area to keep up with the pace that they
can put up where they normally deal with
male ballots
but we've done a very good job of
accommodating that we got equipment
with help from the federal government
from the secretary of state who's been
very supportive in everything that we do
and our local government here in clark
county
we knew the equipment that we needed we
implemented
exactly what we could according to the
budget and
we got ourselves in a good position to
put us right now in a great position to
finish on time
also with the special session this
summer
they gave us additional days to count
that was critical to us being in the
position that we're in right now
had they not given us days prior to
election day and an extension
we wouldn't be where we are right now so
legislators
all of the political figures here in
nevada did a great job of listening to
election officials and us telling them
this is what we need
in order for us to properly process
ballots so
that that's where i feel we stand thank
you i just have one quick follow-up for
you
what is your reaction to the projections
from multiple news organizations that
joe biden is the president-elect
i don't really have any reaction we
we've got our work to do here we can't
stop what we're doing
um i feel good for those election
administrators who where the calls goes
in you obviously
feel good but that call has not been
made for nevada so
we're still working as hard as we can to
get things completed so thank you for
those questions
next
i'm sorry to ask you more questions
about numbers but do you have the
partisan breakdown on the 34
743 drop off mail ballots
oh i see what you're saying from the
election day dropping the election do we
know how many are democrats
i don't have those broken down i have
the total breakdown well no i don't have
those broken down
and then the uh the 44 000 ballots that
needed the id cure or
id was needed was that included in the
provisional ballots or is that a
separate universe of ballots
there are a lot of ballots that are in
that group it could be
the online ballots the mail ballots so
they're different groups that require an
id that
didn't provide okay so they are spread
across those ballots
and then yesterday the federalists
reported that a man who died in 2017
named fred stoke jr had his ballot
returned uh are you or the secretary of
state's office investigating
i'm not aware of that case but we
certainly will if it's brought to my
attention
and do you compare your voter rolls to
the social security death index
we have several reports that come
through from several entities to clean
up our voter roles
hi thank you for taking these questions
you had mentioned additional equipment
and staffing capabilities that were
aided you from the state and the
locality can you talk a little bit more
about when you got that additional
capacity and what it looks like
well starting in march when we became
aware of us being
having the need to send out bail ballots
to all voters as
directed by the secretary of state we
immediately began work
in contacting our vendor or a proposed
vendor for
our mail ballot processing machine which
has made a huge
impact on our ability to count ballots
so the agilis machine
came in uh it obviously it took some
time to get it delivered and get it
implemented we
we use it in the primary election uh we
continue to use it now for the general
election
we immediately well the in-person voting
in the primary was very different than
what we provided
for the general there was only uh one
early voting site and three election day
sites but moving to the general
immediately in june we started working
with risk management to develop a plan
on exactly what we do to set up sites so
they were safe for voters and our
workers
and there was an increase in funding to
us because we needed to buy
shields to protect the voter from the
clerk we needed to buy ppe we needed to
buy cleanser
another outstanding group who has
supported us the mac
our fire chief here steinbeck has done
an excellent job of not only serving the
election department but the entire
county
with what we needed for ppe so that was
a big scale up
and then of course the personnel my
staff did an excellent job of
identifying personnel that we would need
in every area so that we could increase
that we got an increase in funding we
used a
much larger amount of agency temporary
employees because we were unable to
hire what we needed through our normal
process because
in the past a lot of our workers are
senior citizens and they love doing that
work and they do an excellent job of
doing it but
they're more susceptible to the pandemic
so god bless them they just weren't
comfortable coming and working in large
groups so
i think those were areas where we got
the resources that we definitely needed
complete support from the state the feds
and local government
and how many people are counting at a
time right now and is that different
than how many people were counting at a
time
on tuesday or wednesday um that's a
difficult question for me to answer
right now it's a large number of people
that are working to count
uh in all of the processes i i know
we're well over 200 people that are
working to get everything
finished up and we are on schedule we
will definitely finish on time
hey joe joe bartel's 13 action news here
in las vegas um
you've been asked several times we'll
ask again have you had any
nefarious any illegitimate voting any
voter fraud known to you
your office up to this point now up to
this point
especially since we began broadcasting
these news briefings
we do have some reports that have come
in that we're logging we're reporting
we're definitely going to do an
investigation and we'll deal with them
once the canvas is finished
the votes are in the system at this
point so we'll have to
after the election post election go
after anything that's been reported at
this time
hi um i've been talking to a lot of the
voters who are concerned about the
integrity
of the results one of the things that
they're referencing is something that
happened
in michigan when with a voting system
that you use
here with dominion voting systems the
error there had to do
with human air combined with software
not being updated correctly and
tabulations
changing based off of that so one can
you
confirm that your software systems that
you're using here have been
fully updated and match with what the
secretary of state has
and second what do you have to say other
than that about people concerned about
that software system
let me let me open up in my response on
that and saying i'm not certain what
michigan uses
just because we have the same vendor
doesn't guarantee that we're using the
same voting equipment or
tabulation system but as far as clark
county and what we've done
we're state statutorily required i
should say
to verify the hash code on our software
to verify the hash code on all of our
systems
and everything here has been verified to
match
the certification codes that are
provided by nist for the hash code
and what the secretary of state has
instructed us to do in addition to that
statutorily here we have to create a
certification board that's made up of a
bipartisan group of
citizens from the public that have an
opportunity to participate
in our process to ensure that the votes
are being correctly counted
and there's three stages of that that's
one that happens right before early
voting starts one that happens right
before election day
and then there's a post certification
activity after the election
and in all three cases our our software
came out spotless
so we give them a predetermined total on
what we expect the vote turnout to be on
our system
and then we re test ballots into the
system and they go through and verify
that the matches
the accounts match so that's part of
what the state requires
all of our equipment here in the clark
county is federally certified for use
on the voting machine side as well as
the tabulation software
um so we've done everything correctly
we're now
performing our post-election audits
where we have to
again certify the software on our voting
machines
and also on the voter verified paper
trails confirm that those are counting
correctly
so we we do a multitude of things here
to verify that the system is correctly
working and everything is certified but
i can't ask your question in comparison
to mission i don't know what they run
next question anymore
i want to thank all of you for your
participation i kind of wish i had done
this yesterday when the group was larger
it's a very difficult job we're trying
to do and i appreciate what you guys are
doing for the community
and asking these tough questions
although it raises my blood pressure
tremendously
i do the best that i can to be honest
with what we're doing to make the
the public confident that we're doing
what we need to do here to uphold the
integrity of the process which is
what the secretary dictates and what we
always hold is our number one
objective so thank you very much and
have a good day